le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
dans beaucoup de couples réunionnais les
deux parents travaillent pour s'en
sortir financièrement faire garder son
enfant en bas âge est donc une nécessité
pour certaines familles
chaque année la réunion comptabilise 14
mille naissances et les parents doivent
faire face à un problème pour la garde
des enfants le plus souvent les jeunes
mamans qui reprennent leur travail font
appel aux crèches mais placer son enfant
dans une garderie ou une crèche devient
difficile car il y a plus de demandes
que de places disponibles
alors comment faire garder son enfant
quand on est au travail
quelles sont les solutions pour résoudre
ce problème on en parle maintenant d'un
lien social
c'est ici à sainte clotilde dans cette
belle et agréable maison que vit à
habite mélissa mélissa est une jeune
femme de 25 ans et ses petits garçons
dont elle s'occupe si bien ne sont pas
les siens elle est assistante maternelle
depuis le mois d'avril
son métier consiste à garder et
s'occuper d'enfants en bas âge à son
domicile
mélissa exerce ce métier par conviction
en effet elle est diplômée
professionnels de la petite enfance
depuis plus de cinq ans et après avoir
travaillé en crèche
elle a choisi de faire le nécessaire
pour être agréé assistantes maternelles
elle peut maintenant s'occuper des
enfants chez elle jusqu'à leur entrée à
l'école maternelle
alors en fait je travaillais quatre ans
et demi on souhaitera d'accueil et
malheureusement j'avais pas vraiment le
suivi des enfants et
donc c'était sous contrat et j'ai décidé
d'ouvrir ma propre entreprise on va dire
on le dit mais on pouvoir avoir ce
justement ce suivi des enfants
donc il fallait vraiment tout refaire
ici avant c'était passé
la verdure c'était pas à les sécuriser
donc mettre des barrières il faut pas
que les enfants ont accès aux cuisines
les produits dangereux doit être ni à la
vigne à la portée des enfants
voilà les places en crèches sont
vraiment restreinte et j'ai vu deux pas
des parents défi des désespérés parce
que ben ali la reprise du travail ils
ont pas de de moyenne gamme je me suis
dit c'est vrai qu'ils manquent d'audace
en maternelle et voilà et effectivement
j'ai beaucoup d'appels de parents qui
souhaitent ailleurs du dos
car enfants les assistantes maternelles
permettent ainsi de soulager de
nombreuses familles en leur offrant une
surveillance personnalisé dans un lieu
adapté
durant toute l'année
pendant les périodes de vacances faire
garder son enfant est très difficile
l'assistante maternelle est donc une
solution pratique et fiable
la garde des enfants reste encore une
difficulté pour certaines mamans alors
le conseil général fait face à ce
problème en proposant une formation et
un soutien financier aux personnes qui
souhaitent faire ce métier pour faire
garder son enfant les gens pensent
beaucoup aux crèches
il ya un beau métier qui existe qui est
celui de l'assistant maternel et une
assistante maternelle elle est agréée
par le conseil général
elle a droit à une formation s'est elle
devient un professionnel payé par nous
et puis elle peut garder les enfants à
domicile avec un lien affectif peut-être
plus étroit et les parents peuvent aussi
avoir des heures un peu à la carte
donc c'est un beau métier et ça
correspond à une belle de monde les
assistantes maternelles vont avoir comme
dans n'importe quelle crèche droit à
tapis d'éveil à des becs des pleurs
super pour qu' il ait de bonnes
conditions pour que les enfants soient
gardés puis ils ont aussi des jeux payé
par le conseil général et des livres
pour avoir les mêmes conditions
pédagogie d'accueil pour tous les
enfants
et puis faciliter également de la part
du parent l'envi le désir de déposer son
enfant chez une assistante maternelle
le conseil général nous aidons hills
accompagnant la petite enfance mais nous
formons les assistantes maternelles
parce que c'est une façon aussi pour
nous se dire que nous donnons de
l'emploi aux mères de familles qui n'ont
pas forcément envie
ne trouve pas du travail à l'extérieur
et donc ça c'est bien
nous créons une activité en même temps
nous répondons a besoin des parents est
un parent peut se taper sur internet et
à voir l'assistante maternelle le plus
proche de son domicile et il peut aussi
se plaint au conseil général et retiré
son enfant si demain il ya des
difficultés puisque nous donnons avec
l'agrément et puis petit petite cerise
un parent peut bénéficier du chèque
marmaille jusqu'a 100 euros
quand il dépose son enfant chez une
assistante maternelle ceci pour
faciliter justement ce lien parce que
nous savons qu'une manque de places dans
les crèches et les garderies en plus du
nombre croissant d'agrément
d'assistantes maternelles le conseil
général encourage les familles
réunionnaises à faire garder leurs
enfants grâce au chèque marmaille la
gare de gouttes moins cher et devient
donc plus accessible
ces solutions proposées permettent aux
familles réunionnaises de continuer à
évoluer dans la bonne direction car tout
le monde a le droit à une carrière
professionnelle tout en ayant des
enfants
deux facteurs indispensables pour un bon
développement économique et social de la
réunion
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais